[Musica]
deve avere la giusta spazzatura
comunque faccio il grafico e queste cose
non le sopporto
come buona non vorrei che poi la
comprate e poi dopo non vi piace mi
rifatte di fare il progetto da capo
ok se dipendesse da obelix innanzitutto
sono veramente molto contento di essere
sul palco del rex perché io sono un
grande appassionato di ted talks me li
guardo da tantissimo tempo mi piace il
fatto che ci sia un sacco di idee e di
cose che prendo
ascolto le idee arrivano si raccolgono e
poi si danno ad altri in vedere non sono
nostre idee vanno sviluppate e poi mi
piace tantissimo il ted perché è un po
come un concerto punk
perché quando tu sali su un palco non
importa se sai suonare è quello che
c'hai della testa che conta l'idea che
sta in quel momento portando fuori è un
altro tipo di ted
che mi piace tantissimo e questo
questo è stato il mio primo the talk da
bambino non sapevo e leggere guardavo le
immagini e mia mamma mi raccontava delle
cose ed effettivamente se avete mai
pensato se ci fosse stato un link tra un
concerto punk e vostra mamma che vi
leggeva le storie da bambina ok il ted
fedex e questo quindi siamo di fronte
alla forma proprio base della
comunicazione immagine è una persona che
legge per conto tuo quello che ha da
dire
e poi ci sono le idee e le idee sono un
mondo incredibile fatto di cose è
difficile da capire è difficile intuire
che alle volte arrivano soltanto perché
ci mettiamo lì a guardare le cose da un
altro punto di vista
le idee contro la creatività in questo
bellissimo libro di bruno munari che è
una specie di mio vate di tutor
illuminato e che si intitola da cosa
nasce cosa e lui prova a spiegare
esattamente qual è la differenza tra le
idee che spesso sono belle ma sono delle
idee certe volte sono irrealizzabili e
un po come un po come decidere di
distruggere una montagna ok è difficile
distruggere una montagna la creatività
invece non cerca di distruggere le cose
e appoggia l'idea ma cerca un motivo un
modo creativo per salire su questa
montagna la creatività gira intorno
all'ostacolo gira intorno alle montagne
un po come quelle stradine no a cui
arrivi un po alla volta per arrivare nel
villaggio che volevate
queste sono delle calze da donna lo
disegnate io ho fatto tutti gli speed
mille cose da solo solo dalle calze da
donna e una volta bruno munari per
questa cosa delle idee che sono un po un
certo modo di vedere le cose da un altro
punto di vista arrivo si racconta che
due munari arrivo in questa fabbrica di
calze da donna
disse al capo di voi avete mai fatto
delle lampade il capo di questo
cacciatori fici no da ora le farete
perché fa clan è
un'idea che avrebbe voluto una
riprendendo la maglia appunto come
suggeriva sarà che come si chiama il
tessuto della delle calze per creare poi
queste lampade da cosa nasce cosa la
creatività serve appunto per vedere gli
oggetti le calze da un altro punto di
vista
c'è un'altra bellissima non so se ti
visto forrest gump ok grande io sono non
so se hai visto mai un pochino
apro un sacco di parentesi ma poi le
chiuderò tutte ok il forrest gump c'è
questa scena incredibile dove lui a un
certo punto del film decide di fare
avanti e indietro correndo per gli stati
uniti e si avvicina a una persona con un
grosso problema
perché avrei viso sempre e questo
momento ma mi fa sempre ridere questo è
un tipo che si è comprato uno stock di
magliette gialle non sa cosa farsene e
allora a questa idea di andare da lui a
chiedergli un disegno ma non sa
disegnare o una fotografia ma non è una
macchina fotografica
perché a questo bisogno di capire come
destinare queste magliette e
non so se avete visto nel frame prima
passa un camion sporca la faccia di
forrest gump gli dà una maglietta di
tanto ce ne ho tante e
nella dell'impronta della macchia questo
uomo vede lo smile e quindi da lì dice
di aver creato poi un un logo che è
stato venduto dappertutto che è appunto
il fascino dello smile le cose non sono
andate così esattamente però è bello
pensare che la creatività interviene
durante gli errori o durante le
casualità
un altro esempio della creatività che mi
fa impazzire e che è alla base del
principio della cultura perché la
cultura cerca di vedere le cose da un
altro punto di vista
ecco una delle uno dei concetti più
interessante ci siamo seduti sopra la
mole vanvitelliana
una volta era un lazzaretto e stato un
scalo merci era un'isola non aveva
niente a che fare con auditorium
concerti mostre io il mio primo la prima
prima mostra qui alla mole vanvitelliana
è stata enzo cucchi 18 anni la macchina
e mia mamma mi aveva dato i soldi e ho
comprato anche il catalogo e quindi le
cose si trasformano le cose hanno
un'altra vita da cosa nasce cosa e qui
appunto siamo arrivati al motivo perché
sono su questo palco se dipendesse da
obelix ok tubi di tor adesso vuoi
provare ad allacciare tutte le cose un
po alla volta
se dipendesse se dipendesse da mobili sì
perché quando ero piccolo e non mi mia
mamma non mi faceva un test ok vi
facciamo un ted da solo mi facevo un
personale mi prendevo asterix e me lo
leggevo non sapevo leggere parole me
l'aveva raccontata così tante volte che
ormai sapevo la storia quindi me li
guardavo da solo anche se non sapevo
leggere e questa e questa cosa mi ha
fatto sempre pensare a un'altra a un
altro modo a un nuovo modo per vedere le
storie di asterix e obelix
conoscete tutti asterix e obelix
se se pro 7 si vede che l'aria
condizionata non funziona datemi un sì
un po più orgogliosa di conoscere storia
allora asterix e obelix sono delle
storie bellissime francesi dove asterix
è il protagonista e io da piccolo mi
sono sempre immedesimato in asterix
perché perché asterix è proprio
esattamente quello che noi vogliamo
essere né storie l'eroe il personaggio
principale quello che ha le intuizioni
quello che sa capire prima gli inganni
quello che poi sconfigge il nemico ma in
realtà poi guardate lo trascrivo stu
talk
e anche biondo
tutti da ragazzi abbiamo cercato quanti
di voi mori avrebbe voluto essere biondi
o state la mano e invece poi nella vita
reale noi non siamo asterix noi nella
vita reale siamo obelix
e obelix e tutto quello che non è
asterix obelix s'innamora obelix piange
obelix ai problemi obelix è veramente un
personaggio molto più complesso di
asterix asterix in trenta episodi non
piange mai non ha mai una disperazione
che non si sa il perché il processo
della trama non si svolge e ti dirò di
più asterix e non si innamora mai ok
questo era per ricordarvi appunto perché
è un obelix è differente da asterix
perché appunto obelix e caduto nel
paiolo cioè che una pentola gigante di
pozione magica sapete no questa cosa non
aveva devo ripetere anche perché sono
nove minuti
guardate questo ci fa impazzire quando
fa o bill hicks dice il guaio è che sono
timido dopo aver ammazzato di botte un
gruppo di romani che saranno sedute su
quei fiorellini che voleva dare a
falpalà che poi in realtà come lui
vedete gli da questi fiori poi scopre
che il suo fidanzato
tragicomiche bellissimo già il nome
fumetto tragico è quindi piange perché
appunto sono infelice perché appunto in
questo momento lui è innamorato e non sa
come gestire questa emozione poi quali
altri problemi a obelix
ad esempio in questo episodio
a fianco
cesare in una delle sue tante imprese
cerca di fare dei soldati femmina per
cui lui non può fare a botte con le
donne quindi è infelice perché pensa di
non servire più a niente non serve più a
niente oppure come tutti noi quando ci
guardiamo allo specchio e pensiamo
sempre di essere troppo grossi no troppo
ccc guardiamo male però e obelix a
questo problema che pensa di essere
magro
ok
e questa è un'altra delle situazioni in
cui mi fa impazzire perché in questo
episodio
asterix capisce cosa sta succedendo e
obelix no e
fuori proprio da
da intuire cosa sta succedendo e poi si
fa vicino ad asterix dicessi pro dopo mi
spieghi cosa è successo perché io sai
quando combatto almeno vorrei sapere per
quale per quale idea sto combattendo in
questo momento
però dicevamo prima
obelix alla pozione magica dentro di se
lui non la deve assumere lui è caduto
nella nella pozione magica per cui
obelix di per sé è sovrumano è lui a ai
superpoteri
volendo lui potrebbe aspettare che
asterix finisca di bere la pozione
magica finiscano gli effetti
dell'attuazione magica su di lui ok e
poi potrebbe sconfiggerlo
e obelix fabrics ai superpoteri
non solo potrebbe sconfiggere a bravura
core chicks che il capo del villaggio
ok attraverso il duello dei capi
diventare il capo del villaggio
attaccare i quattro accampamenti fuori
dalle mura babà al rum laudano 1 tetti
bonum e l'ultimo numero ricordo
aquarium perché sono un po emozionato
potrebbe prendere anche il controllo di
questi quattro accampamenti ok e poi
cosa fare
espandersi arrivare a con date poi
all'utenza che sarebbe parigi dell'epoca
riunire tutte le tribù galli che in un
unico e solo capo obelix e poi una volta
che tu sei potesse il potere in assoluto
nel mondo tu che hai superpoteri perché
no attaccare l'impero romano arrivare
fino a roma destituire cesare e
diventare tu stesso cesare e invece
cosa fa obelix
obelix fa venir obelix è uno scultore
obelix coi suoi superpoteri fa delle
cose che ancora oggi gli studiosi di
archeologia non sanno che cosa servono
pensateci guardate questa immagine l'ho
dovuto ridisegnare perché non volevo
scrivere copyright
ok strange è fatto di tanti menhir
dolmen e menhir che ancora oggi non
sappiamo a che cosa esattamente servono
ok quindi obelix è uno scultore e qui
superpoteri fa delle cose che non si
capiscono ex sono le cose che noi non
capiamo e sono gigantesche e di solito
ce li mettono nelle piazze l'arte
contemporanea
ok obelix con i superpoteri fa arte
ok questo è calder l'ace brancusi ho
scritto ci calder e ieri sera stavo
scrivendo b brancusi
quindi riassumendo se ai superpoteri
obelix potrebbe diventare cesare e
invece obelix con i suoi superpoteri
decide di fare arte
quindi chi ha i superpoteri fa arte
e il messaggio dove lo mette il
messaggio infatti questa puntata è
bellissima perché asterix deve riempire
quel paiolo di soldi però decidono di
fare teatro ea un certo punto obelix e
preso malissimo perché in quel momento
sta dicendo e il messaggio dove lo metti
il messaggio lui deve fare sul palco e
dire qualcosa però non ha niente da dire
ok allora lo dico io al posto di obelix
se dipendesse da obelix non ci sarebbe
la guerra perché o bill hicks non
farebbe la guerra e con i superpoteri si
fa arte
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]